Jason or Jason depending on who you ask
however the creator of Jason pronounces
it Jason stands for JavaScript object
notation
it's a syntax for storing and exchanging
data Jason that's all I say because
Jason is my middle name has the
following characteristics data is in
name value pairs so here's an example
here's the name here is the value here's
the name here's the value and here's the
name and here's a value data is also
separated by commas so you have a comma
after each piece of data curly braces
hold objects so in this name value pair
the value is an object also the entire
thing is an object so you can see the
curly braces and square brackets hold
arrays like this
Jason values must be one of the
following data types a string a number a
jason object an array a boolean or no
jason values cannot be a function a date
or undefined that's one of the
differences between Jason and JavaScript
objects since the Jason format is text
only it can be easily sent to a server
through URL when exchanging data between
a browser and a server the data can only
be text
that's why Jason can be very useful
there are two important methods for
using jason and javascript the stringify
method if you call jason dot stringify
and pass in some jason it converts it to
a string so we just have a string right
here often you'll stringify some jason
before sending it to a server and the
person
whoops got this con in the wrong place
so when we do Jason dot parse and put in
a string that's also in Jason format
it's going to give us an object it's
gonna convert it to a JavaScript object
well that should give you a good
introduction to Jason thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for links and more
information and to the code don't forget
to subscribe and remember use your code
for good